for us it's going to be regaining our
balance after the last eight years power
depends on legitimacy and legitimacy
depends on a perception of competence
and in important ways we've sacrificed
that for us it's a matter of crafting an
international system that both enables
countries to flourish and at the same
time set some parameters within which
they flourish I think it's harder to
know just what the right questions even
are with respect to the revolution in
the life sciences it's easier to see how
it can go wrong people can shut it all
down because they're scared of it and
cause it to show up elsewhere people can
let the genie out of the bottle in ways
that they later come to regret people
can move too slowly and as a result miss
potential huge opportunities I think all
of these more negative outcomes are
risks I think there are risks that will
be exacerbated if the United States
abdicates in the establishment of
international norms in these areas
because I think for all our failings the
kinds of norms we establish are likely
to be more constructive than the kinds
of norms that would be established in
our absence
you